alright let's just start with the
Maricopa I didn't call this one so that
Snider cut thing the thing that people
certain people at least have been going
on about for a while including Zack
Snyder himself and that I said if we are
ever going to see it it's not gonna be
in a truly properly finished state looks
like I was wrong about that so basically
what got dropped to debt well today at
the time of fielding it'll be two days
ago when I get this video out but
apparently Warner Brothers is going to
do what a lot of people either thought
already thought that we're going to do
or have been pressuring them in whatever
way they felt they could get away with
doing which is to release the Snyder cut
of Justice League on to HBO max now it's
not coming out until next year which
should give you an idea of how much work
needs to be done at it so at the very
least I feel vindicated in in my
assertion before of the Snyder cut is
not a finished film that they are just
denying us to be able to see the thing
needs work it needs apparently about a
year's worth of work so at least I was
right about that part so I don't want to
recount the entire story too much long
story short Zack Snyder director up
Batman V Superman and Man of Steel
originally began directing Justice
League he came off the project after its
initial round of shooting because of a
personal tragedy there is debate and
some contention behind the scenes as to
whether he was pressured to leave the
project anyways but I don't want to get
into that regardless he left the project
and did not come back to finish it it
was finished by Joss Whedon who oversaw
reshoots and all of post-production
and the reshoots turned out to be a lot
more extensive than just the standard
pickups that would have been the case
for most films to be coming in for
reshoots and it looked like Whedon did a
fairly serious attempt at restructuring
it which is very evident if you have
seen the finished film of Justice League
it feels very much like something
started by one person and then finished
by another and these two people do not
have the same sensibilities when it
comes to storytelling it has that feel
on it and ever since then people have
been saying we want to see the Zack
Snyder cut there was a lot of question
for a while whether or not such a kind
even exists Zack Snyder himself fed the
fires on that as to why he did that I
actually talked about in the video I
talked about this previously but getting
to it now it does look like he is going
to be given the resources he needs to
finish the film as fully as it is
possible for him to do so that means he
is going to be granted all the footage
that he shot but never got used he'll be
allowed to go in there and edit cut it
together word is that the any unfinished
effects which is gonna be a lot a lot of
unfinished effects will be completed and
new score will be done that's a lot of
work and it's work that I didn't think
was ever gonna happen what I said before
and what has always been my assumption
is if we ever saw this at all that it
would be it would be a work print it
would be something that isn't truly a
finished film not as mainstream
audiences understand them at any rate so
I never thought Warner Brothers would
actually put the money into it that is
necessary to finish the thing how much
money is that it's Hollywood so is
anybody's guess the word is is that they
are budgeting somewhere between twenty
and thirty million dollars to assist
Zack Snyder in finishing this if I were
to guess the actual price tags probably
gonna come closer to fifty but that's
based off that's me not having an inside
source but it's based off
fact that virtually all of these DC
movies have cost them more than they are
willing to admit spending so I'm not
expecting that streak to break anytime
soon so what the first thing if I always
I'm wondering is why because as much as
certain stripes of the Internet are
gonna start hailing this as a wee one
kind of thing I don't think this is them
giving in to fan pressure I actually
think this was something that had
probably been talked about internally at
Warner Brothers for a while not
necessarily something like never gonna
do that but like is this ever gonna
actually be in our interest to do
because like I said in my previous video
the expense of finishing this thing up
is probably more than they will make by
releasing it in any state and it is
actually an extraordinarily Singh it on
HBO max especially this far after the
launch window because that's unlike
video on demand which one wonders if
it'll get that too but if it's getting
put on HBO max probably not it's
probably there to push the service
releasing our video on demand like
something like trolls world tour was you
can get straight-up purchases on that
where is HBO max it's a lot harder to
nail down how much money you actually
generated by it you can look at viewing
numbers and whatnot but it's a
subscription service so you have no way
of knowing if people subscribed for the
purposes of seeing it or are just
watching because they were already
subscribed and yeah okay I'll watch this
and it and just Rob financial profit
generation it's harder to track down
what kind of income its gonna bring them
releasing it that way but here's the
thing
I think the tails the scales rather got
tipped because of kovat 19 and the lock
down and what I mean by that is
virtually every television and movie
production has been shut down
for a while now we aren't gonna feel the
full ripple effects of this for a little
bit because there were obviously some
things that had already been shot and
have been getting released movies are
just kind of on hold so you know once
movie theaters start opening up again a
lot of movies that would have come out
by now are gonna start coming out but
for them to get production up and
running again there is a venture there
is going to be a gap that happens
between when studios and networks and
everybody basically runs out of the
stuff they've already shot and new stuff
that they've made since production has
restarted again isn't ready to go
there's gonna be a gap there and I think
the intra in the interest of filling
that gap maybe what finally made it more
economically viable to produce the Zack
Snyder cut because they basically have
nearly every asset they need the footage
is shot the directors on board yes
they'll have to bring in you know
effects work and other stuff but that is
more viable to do in the current I in
the current situation then things like
principal photography which becomes
incredibly compromised I mean you know
some TV shows are still are trying to
pick up production again and they're
having to change the entire way that
scripts are even written because they
can't have things like fight scenes and
makeout scenes because they need to keep
people a distance as much as possible
so working instead with footage that
they've already got yeah it actually
makes a lot of sense to kind of get this
thing attached some electro so this is
shocked it's like now when maybe it
wasn't worth the expense before so
that's my guess my semi educated guess
as to why this is finally getting clear
of course like let me be clear me saying
that this is the reason why I think
they're actually pulling the trigger is
not to diminish the artistic value of
the Schneider cut I have no idea what
the artistic value of the Schneider cut
is I won't know until I see it but what
I'm saying is that this decision is it
always has been a purely business and
financial decision from Warner Brothers
and up until this point it didn't make
sense for them to do it and now they
feel it does so there it will be very
interesting to see what this looks like
I have a suspicion that the finished
product isn't going to be quite what
some of the people calling for the
sniper cut think they're gonna be
getting and what I mean by that is
something that needs to be remembered is
when the initial shooting happened when
the primary photography happened they
were already they meaning the studio and
Zack Snyder we're already trying to
pivot away from how dark and our BBS was
so that so the original conception of
Justice League may have been much more
directly in line with the tone and the
vibe of Batman V Superman however by the
time they started shooting they were
already trying to lighten the tone of it
now it does seem very apparent that Joss
Whedon lightened it even more than Zack
Snyder had intended to so I have no
doubt that the Zack Snyder cut is going
to be darker and more serious and
po-faced than the cut we actually got
theatrically was but if people are
thinking it's going to be directly in
line with BBS it's not going to because
it can't be they never shot that version
of Justice League they what they shot
the footage that they have to work with
is the lighter than BBS version that
Zack Snyder was already intending to
make again theatrical version even
lighter via Joss Whedon but if you think
you're gonna get something that is a
direct tonal continuation from Batman V
Superman bat
you need to tamper your expectations
because that wasn't even the movie Zack
Snyder was shooting so you need to you
need to be careful about what it is you
expect to get out of this and again
that's not me
digging quality I have no idea what
it'll be like I honestly don't know I
haven't watched justice league since it
came out and I will actually admit to
enjoying that film a bit more than most
people seem to I'm not necessarily gonna
defend it but I did enjoy it but I
haven't gone back and I probably could
if I had a mind to go back and like
really pick apart I bet that's Whedon I
bet that's Snyder and then eventually
I'll be able to have the comparison go
hey I was right but I don't know how
different this is going to be I'm part
of that is I haven't been following
every leak from Snyder about everything
that he said he wanted to do I know
there was word that Darkseid would
appear and Green Lantern and Martian
Manhunter I don't know if all that's
gonna be in there because like
especially with something like Martian
Manhunter and I if I remember correctly
we saw like sketches and concept art but
nothing representing that anything was
shot and that's the big thing here
they're gonna have to make this movie
out of the existing footage maybe they
can get a very limited amount of
additional photography but it's not
going to be massive it can't be a lot of
productions are still shut down there's
still a lot of concerns aside from the
fact that if they want to get this
turned around in the timeframe that they
do they can't spend it shooting a bunch
of new stuff for my money they'll
probably bring in some of the principal
actors to redub lines and to possibly
get a couple of pickup shots in front of
green screen for Corrections like that
but this is not going to be major
reshoot so characters that were maybe
conceived but never shot to appear like
I expect Martian Manhunter to be
probably aren't going to be in this
and something tells me that there are
some people who are gonna look at the
fact that things like that are going to
be missing and claim that this somehow
still isn't the Snyder cut I don't know
um see that's part of what's I'm both
gonna be curious and terrified to see
I'm gonna be curious to see the film I
am going to be terrified at the reaction
when I review it because I have to be
honest
odds are I probably won't like it that
much I didn't really like Man of Steel
and I really didn't like Batman V
Superman so if it's in line with those
even if it is slightly lighter I'm
probably not gonna like it so I'm not
looking forward to the reaction to that
and I'm going to be both curious and
terrified to see what the response from
the people who've been calling for the
Snyder cut is how much they get behind
it how much they vouch for its
authenticity how much will they attempt
to you know gloss over things that maybe
don't line up with what they said they
wanted before I don't know I have
absolutely no idea I'll be curious to
see but it's gonna be a little while
20:21
Snyder cut what do you think about all
this whatever your thoughts are drop
something down about the comments let's
talk about it usual stuff you know what
it is like subscribe
I got a patreon I got social media other
channels etc links in the description
click on them or don't you don't have to
end of the day you're the council I'm
just running the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]